I have the pleasure to introduce
two of our very own students,
undergrad Itoro Atakpa and
graduate student Sergio Hiram
Cantu.
They will guide us in a
reflection on the life
and legacy of Dr. King.
We will hear first from Itoro
and then followed by Sergio.
(OFF MICROPHONE) Itoro.
[APPLAUSE]
Good morning, everyone.
My name Itoro Atakpa.
I'm a junior here.
I'm studying
mechanical engineering
with a concentration
on product development.
And as [? LuLu ?] said, I'm
your undergraduate speaker
for this program.
Oh, also, I want to thank
you all for coming out,
before I jump right
into the speech.
So thank you all for being here.
I'm really honored to
present to you all today.
It's been three years since
I sat in my makeshift study
and pressed Submit on the series
of documents that were supposed
to somehow represent my
character, my ambitions,
and my potential.
I was 16, and I had
labored for hours, stamping
permanently onto a page
intentions and goals
that today, I have not met.
Because my expectations for what
I would grow to consider to be
my crowning achievements
at MIT could have been
based in no sense of reality.
Because I, in reality,
didn't know what MIT was.
MIT is the mecca of innovation
and technology, yes.
The absolute greatest
place in the world
to receive an engineering
education, yes.
A space to conduct
advanced research
and meet genius professors
and students, yes.
But when I take a moment
to consider what has really
shaped my experience and been
monumental in my growth here,
it hasn't been the revving
arms of robots, which--
don't get me wrong-- I do
love, but the warm arms
of the community I've built.
Over these two and
1/2 years, I've
been constantly switching out
and reorganizing the pieces
that construct my image of MIT.
And I want to show you
all that this is not
just an institute,
but a place to grow
in your morals and
your leadership.
Wide-eyed and anxious
in the classic freshman
way in the fall of
2013, I did, in a manner
of speaking, something
that could stop
almost anyone in their tracks.
I met MIT students.
Yes, indeed, the most profound
moments in my experience
here have been the
conversations that I
had, not with
professors or advisors,
but with the fresh-faced
20-year-olds who I happened
to run into in the dining hall
before the chalk-dusted 6:30
study sessions.
The young men and women who wore
their pajama pants because they
were that comfortable
with me, sharing
experiences that
completely floored
me and left me grappling
for a way to take action.
I have, although not been able
to fulfill every eager promise
on my application,
had the opportunity
to do something remarkable.
I've been able to
listen to my peers
tell me about their
deepest insecurities,
their qualms with the Institute.
I remember one day,
about a year and a half
ago, wanting to tell
my close friends
who had been called the "n" word
and told that they don't belong
here, something to
the effect of, that
couldn't have happened at MIT.
But it did.
And things just like it have
happened again and again.
I've heard my peers speak
about feeling unwelcome
on their own campus,
afraid to speak up
in class for fear of
getting the answer wrong
and thus perpetuating
stereotypes.
About feeling
invalidated in regards
to how race and gender have
etched persistent obstacles
into their experiences, told
to let it go and move on.
About having been told
throughout their lives
that they aren't supposed to
be smart, and subsequently,
not forming a relationship, or
fearing their own intellect.
About being told they don't
look like they go to MIT,
or realizing that MIT makes
them no different from the men
and women who have been
victims of profiling and police
violence.
About feeling abandoned,
unfit, under-represented,
and without key resources.
So many times we've laughed
helplessly and held hands,
asking each other rhetorically
how we can possibly
achieve complete
academic focus when
faced with so many
problems beyond just
the ones on our PSATs.
MIT is not just an institute,
because it hasn't just
given me an education in
the traditional sense.
MIT introduced me to the
people who have infected me
with their passion for building
a stronger community and a more
inclusive society, and inspired
me to acquire positions
within the Black Students Union
and the Black Women's Alliance
in order to work
towards bettering
campus life, opportunity,
and our understanding
of each other.
And fortunately, because
I've held these positions,
I can say in a personal,
connected sort of way,
that in this past
year in particular,
we have truly improved
our level of discussion
as a community on race.
Although we have
certainly spoken
in some capacity about diversity
and equality in the past,
we've been more
deliberate in engaging
the variety of sub-communities
and power levels
than at any other time
since I've been here.
We as undergrads have been
able to compose a strong list
of recommendations.
We as faculty, staff,
administrators, and students
have been able to
form a sisterhood
and share our stories
through My Sister's Keeper.
We as a community have been
able to maintain a dialogue
through Ask a Black Person and
other organized discussions.
That level of impact
makes me extremely
proud of the MIT community.
Especially my peers,
who have stepped up
and had the courage to
spearhead many of these efforts
and to get so many
other people on board.
It is for this
reason that I can say
to my peers in the MIT
community, one thing
that I know without
a doubt about them.
You are a contagion.
You are everything
they say you are
in the books and the movies.
Your words have this power to
hold like glue on the mind that
takes them in, and then
compel that mind share
them and spread them.
And this is a power
that, like all, comes
with great responsibility.
I challenge you to infect
others with your voice.
The voices in your
head don't have
to be a silent and
personal affliction.
They should be an epidemic
on the grounds of our campus.
Because you are
the revolutionary.
You are the difference.
And I know from experience
that once someone catches
wind of your emotion and listens
to your thoughts and ideas,
the virus of your voice
is chronic and incurable.
The greatest recent
example of this
is the aforementioned
list of recommendations,
which has now received backing
from the Academic Council.
The list was made
possible largely
because we have
been able to speak
amongst ourselves consistently.
To the point where we
all, through our own
or through others'
experiences, have
this mutual knowing of what
our challenges are here at MIT.
We all can say in
one united voice
that we need representation
and mental health.
And that we need faculty
that truly values
the well-being of the students.
And that we need diversification
of our departments.
And that we must
teach our students
at least some basic knowledge
about the institutions
of racism, and how they
are harmful to the growth
of our society.
Thus, as an undergrad
who is, in some sense,
at least representing
some of us here today,
I want to invite you
all to our table.
And what I mean
by that is, I want
us to further this trend
of the kind of conversation
that made the list of
recommendations possible.
I want us as the
entire MIT community
to be deliberate in taking
our discussion about diversity
down from the emails to the
types of everyday conversations
that we don't have to suit
up for or be careful about.
The kind that my
peers and I have
at the dinner
table in McCormick,
or the tables in
[? House ?] Two Kitchen,
or the big round table
in the BSC Lounge.
Where we don't have to navigate
so carefully that we miss
some key points or sentiments.
Everyday conversation,
especially when
it transcends the boundaries
of faculty, staff, student,
administrator, has
the power to lend you
an enormous amount of
perspective, an amount that's
completely unparalleled
by anything
with a header and a salutation.
Here at MIT, we
lead in innovation.
We lead in research.
We lead in the financial
and career success
of our graduates.
And now it is time for
us to lead in action.
To set an example for
our peer institutions
on how to conduct community-wide
diversity and inclusion
efforts.
As MLK once said, "The
function of education
is to teach one to think
intensively and critically.
Intelligence plus
character-- that
is the goal of true education."
We cannot allow the Institute
to exist without making
a deliberate effort to develop
this kind of character.
To encourage the facilitation
of the conversations
that we continually avoid
on account of discomfort.
If we truly want
continued progress,
we have to learn that we are
not at the mercy of discomfort.
We are not at the
mercy of discomfort,
and we must learn
to overcome it.
We must learn how to look
directly into someone's eyes
when we say or listen to
something like, people
don't feel wanted here.
We have to explain
and hold accountable.
We have to learn how
to listen to others'
misunderstanding
of our sentiments
without shutting down.
Because in my
case, for instance,
growing up in a
Nigerian household,
and going to a subpar
public Georgia high school,
and having separated
parents, and having
some relatives who
went to MIT before me,
and some who never made
it out of the village--
all of these things matter.
But we have to be proactive
in helping each other
to understand why they matter.
This is the only way to identify
and address the resources that
are missing here.
I say to my peers, speak.
Speak about what
can be done better.
Speak about how community
life can be improved.
Speak, and others
will follow suit,
because you are a contagion.
Infect with your voice.
And not every idea will
be gold, but every idea
has validity and power.
We must all speak.
Because we've still got a
long way to go here at MIT.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]